>>Presenter: Hello everybody.
I'm Julie Wiskirchen from the Authors at Google
team here in Google, Los Angeles.
Today, I'm excited to be welcoming Lisa Brackmann.
Lisa has worked as an executive at a major
motion picture studio, an issues researcher
in a presidential campaign, and a singer/songwriter
bassist in an LA rock band.
And she lives right here in Venice.
Her debut novel, Rock Paper Tiger, made several
Best of 2010 lists, including Amazon's Top
100 Novels and Top 10 Mysteries and Thrillers.
She's here today to talk about her second
novel, a thriller called Getaway.
Please join me in welcoming Lisa Brackmann.
[applause]
>>Lisa Brackmann: Hi.
I'm very happy to be here.
Thank you for having me.
I have lived in Venice for over 25 years.
This is actually the first time I have been
in the giant binocular building, so this is
a thrill for me.
As Julie mentioned, I write fiction, thrillers.
I like to think they have a somewhat literary
quality.
I'm also very interested in using the suspense
genre to talk about larger issues, because
it's one that lends itself to that.
It's one of the few kinds of genre fictions
where you can talk about big things that are
happening in the world.
I think that it can work really well if you're
careful about how you handle it.
This particular book, the main character is
a woman from Los Angeles.
Her name is Michelle.
She used to live in Brentwood.
She's a recent widow.
After her husband died, she had a nasty shock.
I'll just say that her husband was involved
in real estate finance.
I was writing this book in 2008.
It's where it's set in my head.
You might be able to guess where I'm going
with this.
But her husband basically was engaged in a
Ponzi scheme, lost all of their money, lost
their house, lawsuits and debt.
Michelle is someone who really is at loose
ends with her life, doesn't know what she's
going to do, doesn't know how she's going
to cope with the betrayal and the fact that
she suddenly has nothing.
What she does is she takes a prepaid vacation
to Puerto Vallarta that her husband had arranged
before he died.
She decides she's going to spend a couple
of days on the beach, have some margaritas,
try to figure out what her next step is going
to be.
She's sitting on that beach and she's reading
what we like to call a "beach book."
In Michelle's case, we would call it upmarket
women's fiction.
She's reading this book.
The female character meets an options trader
and a cultured woodworker.
Michelle is reading this and going like, "She's
so going to end up with the cultured woodworker,
because that's how these books work.
You always know how they end about 30 pages
in."
As she's sitting there and she's having some
margaritas, she meets a very good looking
guy on the beach.
She's maybe under the illusion that this is
going to be that kind of a beach book.
They have a few drinks, she takes him back
to her hotel room, and then things go very,
very wrong, because Michelle doesn't realize
that she's in a thriller and not in upmarket
women's fiction.
[laughter] What I wanted to do was write a
noir thriller.
I'm going to do a little reading from the
book.
This is after Michelle has had some misadventures.
Some scary things have happened.
But she's in a taxi going to the airport,
going home to Los Angeles.
As difficult as that is, at this point, she's
just really glad to get away from this, because
it's been an upsetting experience.
She's sure everything's going to be fine.
But she's only on page 41.
[laughter] So the odds are not good.
[pause]
[begins reading]
"The taxi chugged up the hill, heading in
the opposite direction of the airport at first,
then around a tight curve that straightened
into a road heading north.
Condos at the crest of the hill morphing into
colonias as they descended.
The road widened, dirt shoulders on either
side, concrete shoring up the hillsides covered
with graffiti and political posters, mostly
for PRI and PAN.
Michelle couldn't remember what the party
stood for here, though she thought that "pan"
might be Spanish for bread.
She leaned against the back seat, eyes half
closed.
She had the beginnings of a headache.
'I shouldn't have had those drinks,' she thought.
'As soon as I get home, it's back to the regiment,
the workout routine, the yoga, the raw food
and greens.
Definitely no margaritas.'
The calories in one were staggering.
The taxi driver muttered something under his
breath that sounded like a curse, put his
foot on the brake, and pulled over onto the
dirt shoulder.
'What's wrong?'
The driver jerked his thumb behind them.
'Polícia.'
She turned and looked out the rear window.
A squad car, black and white, compact, a little
battered, light bar flashing blue and red.
'Great,' Michelle thought.
Had the driver been speeding?
Was a tail light out?
She tried to leave plenty of time to get to
the airport, but she'd heard that things with
the police could turn complicated here.
Well, there was no point in panicking.
The policeman approached the driver's side
door.
Best not to get involved, Michelle decided.
She stared out the passenger window.
They'd parked at the edge of a lot that locked
like an ad hoc body shop, with cars in various
states of assembly: stacked side panels, bumpers,
and doors.
A tin roof propped up on poles was the only
indication of any permanency.
'Odd,' she thought.
'What would stop someone from coming in at
night and stealing parts?
Maybe the workers slept here.
Maybe the whole operation was somehow magically
picked up at dusk and reassembled the next
day.'
She could hear the policeman and the driver
exchange a few low words.
'Ahora al puerto' was one she caught.
The policeman rapped his knuckles on the back
seat window.
'Señora.'
'What?
Excuse me?'
The policeman gestured for her to open the
door.
She did.
'Su bolsa.'
My, purse.
She could feel her heart pound in her throat.
Was this some kind of shake down?
A robbery in the guise of a traffic stop?
What was she supposed to do?
She handed him her purse.
The policeman opened it, riffling through
the main compartment, opening the interior
zip, then moving to the exterior pockets.
It was a Marc Jacobs Hobo, and there were
a lot of them.
The policeman extracted a brown paper packet,
folded, a square the size of a lopped off
business card.
He opened it.
'Come out of the car.'
'What?'
'Out of the car.'
'What is that?'
Michelle asked.
'I-- I don't know what that is!'
'Now!'
'That's not mine.'
He grabbed her wrist and pulled her toward
him.
Lawyer.
How did you say 'lawyer'?
The only word Michelle could come up with
was 'albóndigas,' and that, she was fairly
sure, meant 'meatballs.'
Sitting in the back of the squad car seemed
so unreal, she couldn't process it.
The seat smelled like beer-scented puke.
The policeman had cuffed her, hands behind
her back, and tight enough to hurt, taken
her luggage out of the taxi and thrown it
next to her.
Was he even a real policeman?
He looked like one, she thought.
A big man with a big belly and a mustache
and aviator sunglasses.
His uniform looked real.
The squad car looked credible, too.
Now and again, the radio squawked and broadcast
chatter.
'Dónde vamos?' she managed.
'A la cárcel.'
'What?'
'Jail.'
The policeman barked out a laugh.
'Tienes drogas, go to jail!'
'Drugs?
I don't have any drugs!'
He shrugged fractionally, shoulders tense,
hands gripping the wheel.
A setup, she thought.
It was some kind of setup, a con, a way to
extort money.
'Look,' she said.
'This is a misunderstanding.
Can't we work this out?'
As soon as she said it, she knew she'd made
a mistake.
'What do you think, lady?
You want to give me something?'
'No, I-- I just--' 'Money, maybe?
Something else?'
He laughed again, all the while staring straight
ahead.
'It's a misunderstanding,' she repeated.
'I'm not trying to insult you.'
'You want to give me something?
You want to stop right here?'
The squad car slowed.
On one side of the road, there were cinder
block buildings, apartments, mostly, a few
downtrodden businesses, peeling hand-painted
signs, rusting cars, broken down fences.
On the other, a steep hill, dirt roads, shacks
interspersed among browning vines and palms.
'No,' she said.
'No.'
The car sped up again."
[stops reading]
So yes.
We leave her in a rather difficult place.
I'm going to talk a little bit more about
the book.
I'd like to encourage you to ask questions,
because I'm really more comfortable asking
questions than I am just standing up here
and talking.
But a little more background about it.
After my first book, which was set in China,
I didn't want to do another book that was
set in China.
I wanted to try something different.
I picked Puerto Vallarta because it's an environment
that I know pretty well.
I've been there about a dozen times and felt
that I could treat it credibly.
Given that, it then became, "Well, what kind
of a story could I set here?"
I wanted to do a noir thriller, which, in
my definition, is, basically, you have a woman
or a man with some troubles, and she meets
a woman or a man who is trouble.
Then things go very, very wrong.
Puerto Vallarta has a very large ex-pat community.
A lot of North Americans who go there for
the cheaper cost of living.
I wanted to set it primarily among the ex-pat
community because it was very important for
me not to do, "Ooh, scary Mexico book" although
I think this passage, it does come across
like that.
The heroes and the villains, if there are
any heroes, are mostly Americans who live
in Puerto Vallarta.
Then you look at what kinds of issues can
you base a thriller around.
Drug cartels were a pretty obvious choice.
But the book, to me, is not primarily about
drug cartels.
I wasn't trying to do a journalistic exposé
of that.
I was really more interested in dealing with
the larger issue of corruption.
Michelle's husband was involved in corruption
in the banking crisis.
Though these forms of corruption don't generally
result in headless bodies on street corners,
they still devastated hundreds of thousands
of people's lives.
I don't even think we can count up the damage
that the banking crisis has caused.
If it's a drug cartel or a banking cartel,
whatever it is, to me, they're different forms
of the same kind of problem, which is greed
that's unrestrained by morality or legality.
Michelle, although she--.
The main plot point in the book is she has
to survive this situation that she's gotten
herself into.
To a large extent, for me, the book was about
Michelle coming to grips with the corruption
in her own life, how she picked a comfortable
lifestyle where she wasn't asking questions,
even though she knew something was wrong,
because she didn't really want to know.
She had her life where everything was easy
and pleasant.
Even though she knew she needed to make some
changes, she kept putting them off, because
it's just easier to stay in the same place
when it's a comfortable place.
She has to come to grips with how she enabled
corruption in her own life.
Then, what happens when you go from being
in a position of privilege, which she was,
to suddenly having all of that ripped away
and not having the resources or the wealth,
and realizing that in the kinds of systems
in which we live, that can very easily make
you a disposable person.
One of the things that you see in Puerto Vallarta,
which is a beautiful place--.
I had to say in the acknowledgments in this
book, "Don't let this book scare you away
from going.
I go there all the time.
I really like it."
But you really do see very concrete evidence
of the disparity in wealth.
You have rather wealthy tourists enjoying
these beautiful beaches and resorts.
You have ex-pats who come here because the
price of living is lower and they can live
comfortable lives that they wouldn't be able
to live in the United States or Canada.
You have some very wealthy people who live
in the community, who are involved with the
real estate.
And then you have a lot of very poor people.
If you sit on a beach and have a margarita,
your waiter is making not very much money.
It's hard to survive.
During the summer slowdown, it's very difficult
for most of the local people to make a living,
because so much of the economy is based on
tourism.
You have this constant stream of beach vendors
who try to sell you things.
You sit there and it's like, "Braids, scarves,
jewelry, serapes?"
They are making a marginal living at best
doing this.
There are a couple of scenes in this book
that take place in the old municipal dump,
which I visited.
I had the opportunity to go, and I was like,
"You know, this has got to be noir.
I've got to go see this."
It is what you imagine it to be, except a
lot more.
It's a lot more intense.
There's a whole group of people who make their
living scavenging things at the dump, because
nothing is-- things aren't recycled separately.
They're up there in this intense heat on this
literal mountain of trash.
The city has now grown around.
It used to be out in the countryside, and
now you stand up there and it's like resorts,
New Vallarta, the university, and the giant
mountain of garbage.
They're ripping open these bags and sorting
all of this stuff by hand.
There's stuff up there like when you butcher
a cow, all the extra parts end up somewhere:
there.
It was pretty intense.
I'm going like, "Well, this is a little on
the nose, but what can you say about the way
things are set up, where people are making
their living gleaning what might be valuable
from other people's trash?"
Those are the kinds of things that I was thinking
about when I was writing the book.
I tried very hard not to be didactic about
them, because nobody wants to read somebody
standing up here, talking like me, about stuff
like that.
But it was very important for me to talk about
it, because that, to me, is what the book
is really about.
And, will she get away with her life?
You know.
[pause]
If any of you'd like to ask any questions
about the book, about writing, about publishing,
I would really be happy to take questions.
>>Male #1: Hi there.
This will be my introduction to your work.
I'm not familiar with your previous book.
I'm looking forward to it.
I'm just curious what got you started into
writing fiction?
>>Brackmann: I think it was one of those things
I was born with.
I remember when I was about five years old
that I was going to write my epic of the cats
who went camping.
This was going to be my first big novel.
It got stalled because I didn't know how to
spell "tent."
I sadly had to abandon that project.
But it's something that I always wanted to
do.
I think most people that are writers come
to it.
I just remember the first time that I opened
a book.
I opened a book, and for whatever reason,
I could read pretty much immediately.
It wasn't a big learning curve, it was just,
"Wow!
Words on a page that tell us a story."
I thought this was the most miraculous thing
ever.
Then, I think, as I got older, – so I've
written most of my life, on and off.
I've gone through periods where I wasn't doing
it as actively, where I tried to do other
things.
But I'm someone, I like to travel.
I like to observe.
I like to try to figure out how I think the
world works.
What's going on here?
How are these things put together?
What is it we're all doing?
I don't--.
Writing non fiction doesn't have the same
appeal to me as trying to take these sorts
of issues and questions and cast them in a
fictional form.
I think it's as much about making sense of
the world as I observe it, as anything else.
That's my motivation.
And having fun.
Writing books like this is fun.
You know?
It's like, "Oh, what horrible thing can I
make happen now?"
[laughs] I don't know, maybe there's an element
of masochism.
I'm not sure.
>>Presenter: I'm just curious about how you
got your first book published, and the process,
and how long it took you to work on it, and
so forth?
And editing, and all of that?
>>Brackmann: Anybody that is involved with
the publishing industry these days, will tell
you that it's an industry that's--.
There's a lot of changes that are taking place.
There's a lot of uncertainties.
My other author friends, I think that the
line we always fall back on is "It's a brutal
business" because there's an element of luck
involved as well, and timing.
It's kind of like you find the right project,
the right person, at the right time, and all
those windows have to line up.
There are certain things you can do to improve
your chances, but you're always going to be
dealing with that.
In my case, I decided that I wanted to write
something that I could sell, because I've
been writing most of my life, but not really
with the intent of selling something.
It was just something that I did.
I thought, "Well, what can I write about that
is commercial, that's going to have some appeal
to people, that I know about?"
And contemporary China was my choice.
I've been traveling there for about 30 years.
Then it was just, "Well, let me find something
I'm really angry about" which would have been
the Iraq war and the war on terror.
And then, "Let me figure out how I would talk
about contemporary China and the war on terror
and put those things together" which was an
awkward fit.
I characterized it like you're juggling a
bowling ball, a flaming torch, and a chainsaw,
and trying to get these things to work and
play well together.
I came up with what I came up with.
I worked on the book.
Then I just did that thing that they tell
you to do, which was I started querying agents.
If you're familiar with the process, you create
a query letter, which is basically a pitch
for your book.
You make it sound like [laughs] like the flap
on the jacket.
A little bit about yourself and why you're
the person who's writing this book.
And you send it off.
I did about six of these and didn't really
get anywhere.
I discouraged very easily at the time.
I was like, "Oh, I wrote another really weird-ass
book that no one's going to publish."
Then a friend of mine says, "Why don't you
query this guy, Nathan Bransford?" who was
a well known agent, if you're in the blogging
publishing world at all.
I did, and he wrote me back right away and
said, "Oh, this is really interesting.
Can you send me the partial?"
I sent him the partial, which is usually the
first 50 pages.
A couple of hours go by, and it's like, "Can
you send me the book?"
And I did.
And then, we worked together revising the
book, because it was pretty unwieldy.
There were a lot of different things going
on.
One of the things that you learn when you're
doing this is your fiction has to fit somewhat
into a category, which can be very frustrating.
But it's largely about--.
Even with the reduced role of bookstores,
it still comes down to "Where does this book
go on the shelf?"
If you can't answer that question, you're
making your task of selling the book that
much harder.
A lot of what I did was cutting away stuff
that got in the way of the first book being
a suspense novel.
Then, we went out, after six months or so
of that.
I guess the book itself took me about, it
was close to two years, I guess, the writing
process and the revising process.
A year and a half, two years.
Then we went out on submission.
Right when we went out on submission, it was
middle of 2008, and the entire economy cratered.
It was like, "Oh, great.
My timing is awesome."
My agent, thankfully, he was a very good agent,
and very dedicated, and was going to do his
best to sell this book.
We sent it out in little batches at a time.
It took a year, and then SoHo published the
book, which has ended up being a really great
fit.
They are an actual independent publisher,
but they're distributed by Random House, so
you get the best of both worlds.
So yeah, it was the traditional process.
It's just the traditional process.
There's a lot of different ways to do it now
that weren't available when I was doing it.
The traditional process can be a really long
and hard road.
You just have to be willing to do a lot of
pounding your head against the wall until
either your head or the wall gives way.
That's generally what it takes.
>>Male #2: So you mentioned that you've traveled
repeatedly to Puerto Vallarta and to China.
Where else do you go back to repeatedly, and
what do those places have in common?
What might show up in future books?
>>Brackmann: [pause] Well, China.
Have any of you traveled to China?
Anyone?
It's an incredibly--.
It's a big country, like the United States,
and it's very diverse.
There are a lot of different parts to it.
I was interested in dealing with contemporary
China, which is--.
Most Western authors that have written about
China tend to do stuff that's set in a period.
The reality of China today is very, very different.
It changes very rapidly.
One of the challenges when I was writing Rock
Paper Tiger was I had to keep updating it,
even as the book was in galleys.
Like, "Oh, they don't use this kind of car
for taxis in Beijing anymore.
Whoops.
Let me fix that."
I don't know that it really--.
I guess what the two books have in common,
well, in the first book, the one set in China,
the main character has lived in China for
a couple of years, in Beijing, so she has
some basic familiarity with her environment.
She can speak the language decently.
She can navigate, up to a point.
But she still is an outsider.
In this book, this is a woman on vacation
who's just completely, you know, from Brentwood!
[laughs] She's not prepared to deal with what
she runs into at all.
It really takes her a while to--.
I get a little frustrated by thrillers where
everybody understands they're supposed to
act like they're in a thriller right away,
because that's just not very realistic.
I'm more interested in what somebody, quote
"an ordinary person" would do who's in an
unfamiliar environment and really doesn't
know what's going on or how to navigate or
what a smart choice is, and doesn't have a
lot of resources to figure those things out.
Both of the books have that element somewhat
in common, where an ordinary person without
super martial arts powers or hacking skills
gets involved in an extraordinary situation
that is way above their pay grade.
That would be the main element in common.
I have a third book that I've sold that's
coming out May next year that is actually
a sequel to the first book.
It's going to go to different places in China
than the first book went to, because I like
to give a little bit of a travel log.
We're going to some pretty places.
I call it a "lighthearted romp through an
environmental apocalypse."
[laughter] Although we do go to some pretty
places in the book, too.
Yeah, I'm just going to call all my books
lighthearted romps.
This is a lighthearted romp through the wonderful
world of black ops and drug cartels.
Lighthearted romp through an environmental
apocalypse.
Like that.
Because I think that the stuff I write has
an element of humor in it.
I don't know whether that comes across as
clearly as I think it does, but I like a little
bit of satire or humor in it, as well.
>>Male #3: It sounds like you've been writing
Americans in international territory where
they're unfamiliar--
>>Brackmann: Mmhmm.
>>Male #3: --and have to respond and react.
In the future, have you thought about maybe
doing foreigners in America, and what they
have to go through?
>>Brackmann: I think I wouldn't be against
that.
I'm not one of these people that thinks that
somebody from one particular background can't
write about somebody from a background that's
different.
I do think if you're going to do that, you
really, really, really have to do your research,
and you really have to be familiar with the
person, with the culture, with what it is
that you're trying to portray.
I would only approach that if I felt that
it was something I could do credibly.
I had enough trouble in the first book because
I had, the main character was in the National
Guard, and I have not been.
That was something that I really, really immersed
myself in.
I was really gratified when I got some feedback
from vets who asked me if I'd served and told
me that I'd done a really good job with it.
That was very meaningful to me.
But you really have to do your homework.
And actually, I'm not-- the fourth book is
still a little bit up in the air, but it's
going to be set primarily in the United States.
I'm hoping to have--.
It's going to be serious subjects, some very
serious stuff, but I think the element of
satire will be a little bit more apparent,
because I'm going to do a political campaign,
among other things.
I'm looking forward to doing that.
So the character, in this case, is going to
be a little bit better at operating in the
environment.
>>Female #1: I've read both Rock Paper Tiger
and Getaway.
I think you do a fantastic job of, as you
said, layering-- that's my word, but-- layering
the social issues that you want to talk about
in your books with actual plot.
It makes me wonder how much you outline, if
at all.
Maybe give us an idea of what your actual
writing process is.
>>Brackmann: [chuckling] Outline?
What is this outline?
It really--.
It's interesting, because I just wrote a piece
about how I plot, how I create story for a
collection that's going to be coming out in
a couple of weeks.
I really had to think about it.
It wasn't clear to me until I started thinking
about the fourth book how I do it.
The fourth book is actually a little bit more
organized already than I usually--.
I've learned a little bit.
I don't like outlining because I feel like
a lot of times, I get to know my characters
as I write them.
It's almost like it's a process of observation,
like I'm watching these people and trying
to, like, "What are they doing?
How do they act?
What's their thing?"
I don't like to do too much outlining.
I do tend to take--.
Location is important to me.
Issues are important to me.
And characters.
Then you go, "Okay, what's the driver?"
If I've got these elements, what's the thing
that's going to drive the story?
That's the tricky part, because, especially
when you're writing stuff-- hmm, excuse me--
that is suspense fiction, it needs to be suspenseful.
You have to have something that creates tension,
and you have to create tension all the way
through the book.
You don't want to be too loosey-goosey about
it.
But I think pacing is something that I've
learned over the course of writing three and
now starting on a fourth book.
It gets to be a lot easier to go, cut, cut,
moving on, moving on, moving on.
I have a short attention span, so that helps,
too.
But no, I don't plot, I don't outline.
I try to set up the situation so that the
story can then unwind, like, okay, if you
know you have this character in this setting
with these problems, and this thing that has
to-- that she's got to deal with and solve--
then what happens?
But I always tell people everybody's process
is different.
I'm a real believer in not instructing people
on their own process.
It's something you need to discover through
work.
The only thing that I say is that I really
think it's a good idea to write every day,
if you can, especially when you're working
on a project, because--.
For me, if I take too much time off, then
there's this process of reacclimating myself
and getting back into it.
My productivity just goes way down.
Whereas if I work every day, I don't have
to put in a lot of hours trying to write,
but I get a lot more done in the same amount
of time.
Setting a schedule is helpful, which was one
of those really hard things for somebody like
me to admit.
I hate schedules.
I hate them.
You know what, really, it works better if
you do that.
Whatever works for you.
I used to write, when I had a full time job,
I wrote from 10 to midnight pretty much every
night.
>>Male #1: I have another question, too.
This is related to the character, your characters.
How much of yourself finds its way into your
main characters?
Do you explicitly try to refrain from doing
that?
>>Brackmann: I think that most people that
are writing--.
Well, not everybody, because some fiction
authors will talk very explicitly about how
"This is kind of like me, but a more idealized
version of me."
I'm the opposite.
"Well, there's elements of this that are like
me, but a more screwed up version of me."
I don't want to write about myself.
I think a lot of fiction is disguised biography,
because obviously, everything is coming out
of your own head.
But that's the heroes and the villains.
It's the whole, everything you're writing.
You're taking little pieces of yourself.
And empathy, which I think is the most important
thing, and trying to understand how this person
would react, placed in these situations.
Not me, no.
Mm-mm. [laughs] And especially, I really tried.
The first book, the main character is young,
swears a lot, drinks a lot, does a lot of
really questionable, because she's really
screwed up.
When I wrote the second book, I wanted to
prove I can actually write an entire book
where the f bomb doesn't get dropped every
paragraph.
I'm going to do it right here.
I think also, and again, depending on the
kind of writer you are.
I don't want to do the same book every time.
I'm not interested in dealing with the same
main character every time.
Though I'm doing a sequel to the first book,
and it's written, and, it was really fun.
It was really fun to go back to that character.
It was really fun to deal with some other
issues in her life.
I had a blast with it, but I can't see myself
writing these books and this character in
the alphabet, like Sue Grafton did.
I'm going like, "I want to do maybe one more,
and then I'm done with that."
I think mainly what it is is you have to understand
your own emotional responses to things to
realize that other people's emotional responses
aren't the same as yours.
I think empathy, understanding yourself, is
certainly important.
Observation and empathy are the other things
that are really important.
I would be pretty horrified by books that
were populated by myself.
I don't think I'd want to read those.
[laughs] I know I wouldn't want to write them.
[laughs]
>>Presenter: Non writing question.
Since you've lived in Venice for a while and
some of us are new to Venice, I wondered if
you had any recommendations about the neighborhood?
Restaurants or things to do, and so forth,
that are your favorites?
>>Brackmann: I love Venice, and it's changed
a ton since I, I moved up here, I can never
remember.
It was December '86 or December '87.
I lived in this building on the Boardwalk
that was one of the "Jim Morrison slept here"
buildings.
He slept around, man.
[laughter] There's a lot of those.
It was the kind of thing where you'd have,
it got turned into an illegal hostel, and
there were guys that would steal things from
the top floor.
I was on the bottom floor and they'd come
and knock on my door at like 8 in the morning
and say, "Do you want to buy a microwave?"
I'd be like, "No, I don't want to.
Get out of here!"
We had SWAT teams.
It was fun.
Venice.
Fun.
A little edgier than some of us, than anybody
really liked.
But that kind of thing, I think it's--.
It's safe here.
It's a great mix of people.
You have people that have lived here for generations.
You have all kinds of artists, film industry
people, and now, this whole silicon beach
thing.
It's a very--.
It's always been a very creative place.
It's still a very creative place.
It's just manifesting itself differently than
it used to.
Being able to walk through the neighborhood
at night and not worry so much about getting
shot is a very cool thing.
That's the upside of gentrification, I will
say.
And wine bars is the other upside of gentrification.
We have a lot of them.
Rose Avenue has really developed quite a bit.
That's booming, and it's still kind of charming.
Oscar's.
Have any of you been to Oscar's or Venice
Beach Wines?
Those are great.
They're great little places, and the owners
are really, really cool people.
And then, I really like, on the Boardwalk,
the Venice Ale House.
It's surprisingly good.
And then, have you been to Dry Tour yet?
The place that just opened on Windward and
Pacific?
That place I really like.
It's another local, locally-sourced, organic.
But well done, and the prices are reasonable.
And Taco Trucks.
You know, there's one that always parks on
Rose that's called, I think it's Isla Bonita
or something like that.
That's really good.
Abbot Kinney, I like the coffee place, Intelligentsia.
It's over the top, but it's good.
The people, again, they're really nice and
they care about what they do.
The restaurants I don't go to there very much.
Hal's is still kinda cool.
It's old school.
It's been there for a long time.
There's a sushi place that's on the Boardwalk,
of all, in that little food court that's on
Westminster.
There's two things in that.
The Pupuseria is good, and the little sushi
place, which is surprising.
You would not expect that.
I really, I walk everywhere, thus these fabulous
shoes.
I just think that exploring the neighborhood
in general, the different neighborhoods, there's
so much diversity in the housing stock.
It's so much fun just to walk around and see
what you discover.
Have you been to the canals?
All that kind of stuff.
That's, I don't like the way a lot of that's
developed.
But it's still a really fun place to take
out of town visitors.
"Hey, look at the ducks."
Just wandering in this neighborhood, the one
that we're in, which was traditionally an
African American neighborhood, and--.
Do you guys know the history of the area?
Would I be repeating it?
Well, Abbot Kinney, who was a developer, around
the turn of the century, wanted to make Venice.
There were a lot more canals than there are
now.
It was a vacation spot for people who lived
in Los Angeles.
They would summer out here.
I lived in one of those little resort hotels,
with the Murphy beds.
That's what it was designed for.
When he got old, he had a chauffeur and an
assistant, an African American man who couldn't
live anywhere in Venice.
He wanted to leave him some property in his
will, so he established the Oakwood community,
wrote the real estate covenants so that African
American people were allowed to buy and live
there.
Because things were very restrictive.
It was 1920s, something like that?
That's part of the history of the neighborhood,
which I hope doesn't go away in this rush
to megamansions and wine bars, because that
would be a shame.
Because I think what makes Venice interesting
is that it brings so many different kinds
of people together, different economic levels,
different backgrounds.
But everybody, I mean, I think the thing in
common is that almost everybody that's here
likes being here.
If you just wander around and say hi to people,
99% of the people that you meet in Venice
are really happy to be here.
I think that's one of the things that makes
it a really special place.
You just--.
A lot of places, there's a level of urban
alienation.
You don't have that here.
This is a community.
>>Female #3: There's a lot of [inaudible]
here.
>>Brackmann: Yeah.
Yeah, there is.
I think that's one of the best things about
it.
So I was really happy to see you guys move
into this building, because this building
was just getting beat to crap.
It was really run down, and it wasn't being
taken care of.
It's such a great local landmark.
It's nice seeing it here and playing a vital
role in both the community and the world,
really.
We're glad to have you.
[pause]
>>Male #6: A follow up on that question.
Does Venice find its way into your writing?
Not literally, but I guess in a more sort
of general or--?
>>Brackmann: Well, at the place-- I lived
in two places in Venice.
I lived at the Ellison, which was one of these
old apartment buildings on the Boardwalk.
About nine years ago, I moved into a little
bungalow cottage which was built in 1910 that
I call Shack by the Sea that I walk down from.
It's very shack-like.
It's got these big bamboos, and it's wood
and open ceiling.
It's just a very creative environment.
It's the kind of place where I have felt inspired
to do work.
I think Venice in general inspires people
Part of it is that you just meet so many interesting
people.
It's always better to be in a community that's
about fostering creativity in all its different
forms.
So I haven't written about Venice specifically,
but it's just one of the rare places that
I think, its foundation is creativity, from
the moment that it was built.
Who builds canals?
[laughs] Who builds Venice in the middle of
Los Angeles?
Some crazy developer dude.
It started from there, and I think we still
feel that now.
>>Male #7: This is going to reveal my ignorance
of your work, but I was curious.
You set a lot of your books around social
ills or causes.
>>Brackmann: Mmhmm.
>>Male #7: I was interested in how you work
the story around that.
Is it just a setting, or do you advocate solutions,
or how does that affect your characters and
plots?
>>Brackmann: It's like I said.
It's a hard line to walk because I can't stand
reading overly didactic fiction.
It's boring.
I don't--.
I have a short attention span.
So I think it has to be woven very carefully
and organically into this story, otherwise,
you're just going to do a fantastic belly
flop.
I mean, I find it kinda funny, because most
of the people that comment on the stuff that
I write don't even comment about it.
I guess that means I'm successful, because
no body is mentioning, "Oh yeah, this book
is really about", you know.
And how things get solved or don't solved
depends on the issue involved.
That's another thing.
I don't, I get a little bit frustrated.
They're fun escapism, and people get to read
what they want to read.
But when you have some huge world shaking
problem and action man fixes the whole thing
by the end of the book, I'm like, "That never
happens.
It not how stuff works."
I'm more interested in more open ended sorts
of things because some things can't be resolved.
It's really more about how the character responds
than it is about "I'm going to fix the problem
of arbitrary authority that abuses its power"
because one little person is not-- that's
the first book-- is not going to be able to
do this.
It's more just like, "I've already been screwed
over by arbitrary authority that abuses its
power.
I have to figure out how to survive this and
how I'm going to live with this.
How do we live with the fact that so many
things are completely out of our control?
Are these really, really huge, scary kinds
of issues?
What can we personally do?
How much effect can we have on them?
More to the point, how do we live with it?
That interests me more than solving an issue.
I like to deal with things that are not particularly
solvable by one person.
It's more about going like, "Okay, we have
an entire system that is behaving in this
way.
What are we going to do about it?
How do we respond to it?
Is there anything we can do about it?
What positive actions can we take?
More to the point, can I survive the scary
guy with guns who's trying to kill me?"
So yeah, it's a tricky thing to do.
But you've got to really embed it.
Again, the nice thing about suspense genre
is that you don't really have a lot of time
to waste.
You can't take "Now I'm going to stand up
here and explain to you how I feel about the
abuse of the Constitution."
I'm not going to do that.
But yeah.
Sometimes I think maybe I've been more subtle
than I think, because it's like "Yeah, I don't
get what this book was."
[makes whining noises] [laughter] It gets
a little frustrating sometimes.
[laughs] But yeah, you've got to make it organic
to the story.
Well, thank you.
This has really been a pleasure.
I'm so delighted to have met you all and finally
gotten inside the Giant Binoculars.
I hope you enjoy the book.
[applause]
>>Presenter: Lisa will be signing, if anyone
would like to get their book signed at the
table over there.
Thank you, Lisa.